ok good afternoon everybody my name is
Tom Pollard I'm up I
dean of the graduate school and I'd like
to
welcome you to the fourth of our company
of scholars lectures here at the
graduate school for this year this is a
series of public lectures meant to
expose the scholarship of our faculty
here at Yale to a wider audience and in
that regard we've had three very
interesting lectures so far on
completely different topics the first
one by Jacob hacker had to do with
public policy and wealth distribution in
the United States the second by Beverly
gage had to do with J Edgar Hoover and
the foundation of the conservative
movement in the United States the third
one make a deal often had to do with the
impact of religion on parenting in the
United States so we have sort of a theme
of connection between our academic work
and the public for for our lecture
series this year and I selected my
friend paul tipton over here to give
this lecture because he wrote a very
thoughtful op-ed piece in the LA Times
that was distributed to other newspapers
by the LA Times on why the investment
made by the public around the world
through their taxes in this big physics
experiment was worthwhile so his topic
today is finding the Higgs boson what
our taxes taught us about mass so let me
tell you about Paul where he can take
the floor in a moment he has his a
doctor LaBrie from the University of
Rochester inland I went off to UC
Berkeley and to the Fermilab in Illinois
for postdoctoral work returned to
Rochester rose through the faculty to
full professor in two thousand and two
thousand six we lured him here to Yale
he's now serving as the director of
graduate studies in the physics
department and on July first he will be
the next chair of physics here at Yale
so thank you very much for joining us
here today Paul and thank you all for
coming
thank you very much so it is my pleasure
to bring news of a momentous discovery
in physics and I'm sure you've heard
about the Higgs almost everyone you'd
have to really be hiding under a rock or
something to not hear anything about the
Higgs so what I'm going to try to do is
give a talk that complements what I hope
and think you probably already know I
want to start by thanking my my
colleagues both around the world on the
Atlas experiment of which I'm a member
but also my colleagues here at Yale to
be as calling Sarah vtech and keith
baker and also the physics librarian
kaylee and catherine james who is from
the by Nicki so let me start out with a
bit of a warning so in physics the big
three our space-time and mass and as
Kramer's alludes to any any very
important fundamental entity is going to
be hard to us to attach a well
established meaning to and so that's a
bit of a warning i'm going to try to do
that to define and understand mass at a
deep level and and a more succinct way
of saying that is that mass is a mess
and and now Wendy said this in the
context of inertial mass versus
gravitational mass in the lack of a
clear non circular definition but it
leads to the to the same idea so an
outline for today is I'm going to give a
rather lengthy introduction on the
history of mass and how the Higgs
relates to to that and then I'll talk
about the the Higgs search and how we
produce and detect the Higgs boson or
what we think is the Higgs boson what's
next at the LHC and then lessons beyond
sciences as Tom alluded to funding
ethics internationalism in taxes so so
it's going to be a big introduction and
a big conclusion with very little
sandwich of the Higgs search in between
okay so a brief history of mass so and
at the end I'm going to give lots of
opinions and their my opinions and I
apologize in advance if I offend anyone
but I'm going to give them anyways so
and speaking of offending i'm going to
start the history of mass skipping over
the ancients who gave us the theory of
the atom and start right away with with
Newton who gave us a theory of mass that
we could do something with a
quantitative theory with predictive
power Newton in principia the most
important of his works and arguably the
most important document in science today
on the first page of the first book of
Principia he tried to define mass and he
did so a by by you you know it's in
Latin of course so it's a quantity us
materi a which is matter and when would
translate what comes next as matter
arising from its density and volume
conjointly so the problem with Principia
is that it's in Latin for the first
that's of one problem the second problem
is that it's basically math but it's
written in words so he didn't he didn't
basically have the algebraic tools we
have and so when you read it you know
it's like he's playing charades you know
I'm thinking of a oven of an equation
and any you know so in sentient in
paragraph armies so to translate this
into math which would I believe what he
was trying to say is that mass is
density times volume that's what most
people think he meant by that that
sentence which is a bit problematic
because density is mass over volume and
so we basically just go around in a
circle and our confusion about mass I
think can be traced back to this
beginnings where Newton stumbled over to
himself now Newton then went on to you
know with putting aside this circular
definition he used mass to get us F
equals MA and and M being the sort of
the charge of the gravitational force
and and you know operationally we now
can define mass right masses our ability
to resist acceleration because F equals
MA if you've got a big mass you can have
for a certain applied force your
acceleration will be less and and and
similarly in the gravitational equation
so you can you can
you can get somewhere with a circular
definition it turns out so so we owe to
Newton a bit of our confusion now let me
see echo okay so it turns out that this
story has a bit of a local connection
you know these newspapers like to sell
local connection so I'm doing that now
it turns out in 1713 there was a an
agent for the colony of Connecticut in
London and his name was Jeremiah dumber
and he his job among other things was to
gather books for a library for a new
struggling college in Connecticut and he
went calling on the head of the royal
society at the time was Isaac Newton any
asked for some donation of books in
Isaac Newton in 1713 at a new new
version second edition of bring capilla
and he gave jeremiah dumber a copy of
that and optics and a few other things
and we have here that copy courtesy of
the author now it turns out this is
probably the second copy of Principia
that made its way across the pond the
first went to the colony of Pennsylvania
and it was given it was bought by James
Logan so he had to buy they had to buy
theirs and we got ours for free so
that's good but uh he read it and
devoured he that he went on to become
the mayor of Philadelphia but before he
on the way of doing that he taught
himself calculus out of prank epyon he
he devoured any wrote letters about it
and there's scribblings in the margins
and everything it's quite impressive and
I invite you to come and look at this
copy and notice how clean it is so
either we're better to book so we
ignored this thing for many years I
don't know but we shouldn't ignore it
anymore so come in and appreciate the
the fine drawings and great work that it
is okay so after Newton the chemist
Lavoisier and others through studies of
chemical reactions came came to believe
that the the mass of the initial state
of any chemical reaction would would
equal the mass of the final state even
though the initial state might be carbon
and oxygen and the final state might be
co2
and so that they in in their language
mass was neither created nor destroyed
which we now know is not completely true
but back then it was a pretty good
approximation the other thing that they
came upon was that their view was that
mass was inherent in assent an essential
product of an object or material and
that's because if you had a mole of
hydrogen it weighed to certain number of
grams and if it if you had a mole of gas
and it didn't way that it wasn't
hydrogen and so you know mass is an
essential feature of each element and
and it was viewed as such now to make
any more progress on the history of mass
we actually have to step back we're it's
1760 or 1780 and we have to start
learning about fields now the word field
was actually not used until about 1840
but the idea you know was in gestation
and we have a Faraday was was likely the
first one to use it in a scientific
publication so in in about 1810 it was
understood that one could map out in
pictures like like this one how a
positive charge would be influenced by
other charges and these maps were
curious they would tell you direction
and if you plotted the density of lines
you could actually get magnitude also so
they were very helpful inconvenient but
they really weren't viewed as real but
Faraday was a great experimentalist and
he played with gadgets and he came to
believe that in simple electric circuits
energy was taken out of that circuit to
set up a magnetic field and then when
you switched off the circuit the energy
would be dumped back into the the
circuit and so for a physicist if
something contains energy like he came
to believe the field did that was surely
real but he never really said it exactly
like that and it was it was a so he
worked mostly with magnetic charges but
the same thing could be stated about me
I'm sorry with with electrical charges
but the same thing could be said about
magnetic fields around mass I'm sorry
gravitational fields around masses so he
came to believe that fields contain
energy and
was Maxwell later who who showed through
beautiful mathematics that light was
comprised of oscillating electric and
magnetic fields and since we all believe
light is real it's not hard then to
believe that the underlying fields that
that are contained within it are also
real now one might ask our water waves
really real maybe it's just the water
that's real meaning maybe it's the
vehicle or the medium for a wave that's
the real thing but Einstein came to to
take the work of Davisson and Germer and
others who I'm sorry Michelson and
Morley and others who who gave us
evidence that that there is no medium
for light that light is traveling it's
self-propagating and it travels in in
the vacuum and and so if if these fields
are independent of any medium then
clearly they're there in and of
themselves real and they carry energy in
fact later on in general relativity
Einstein told us that that matter can
deform space and time and in fact all
forms of energy can deform space and
time so fields alter the space therein
and so clearly they're they're quite
real so now we can go back to talk about
mass and we're up to about 1910 and we
want to talk about the new idea in 1918
or so that debroy had that that if if
light is both wave and particle the the
particulate nature of light was
described in a paper by Einstein in 1905
if flight is both wave and particle
maybe maybe the electron and all forms
of matter are and by 1925 that had been
experimentally demonstrated so now
quantum mechanics is basically telling
us that light is made out of a quantized
oscillating field and in fact all matter
is also quantized oscillating fields but
their matter fields instead of electric
and magnetic fields so so now fields
have got to be pretty real because they
make up make up pretty much everything
around us in in 1935 you kawa came up
with the idea of how we could actually
do calculations with this idea
how we might be able to see how one
particle influences another and that is
by exchanging a third particle which
incidentally is also made out of fields
quantized fields so so it was fine men
who told us that electric and magnetic
forces on the subatomic level the four
primary particles are mediated by by the
exchange of photons and that was the
first of what we would call a quantum
field theory so just on a macroscopic
level just just as these people if they
were standing on ice could exert a
repulsive force by exchanging a heavy
ball by each pushing against the ball
and accepting momentum from the ball so
on the subatomic level particles can
exchange a third particle and influence
each other so that's that's the basic
idea then it was it was fine man who
made these calculations relatively easy
anybody who's taking graduate quantum
field theory knows that not easy easy
but they're relatively easy and there's
just one idea then to get us to where we
where we are today and that is that in
the mid-nineteen so Fineman did his work
in about nineteen forty eight and by 55
people were struggling to try to explain
the other forces in terms of field
theories to mimic what Fineman did for
electricity and magnetism but it was
young and Mills who made a uh who made a
big discovery and that is that the field
of mathematics called group theory has a
lot of parallels to the quantum algebra
of quantum field theory and and it to
make further progress they basically
said if you find the right group that
will the rules about how this group
behaves will inform the physics and in
fact if you find the right groups you'll
be instantly able to to write down the
rules of the physics and so by nineteen
sixty five or so people were able to
write down a group that encompassed the
the known forces except for for gravity
and so here's a one slide summary of
what we call the standard model of
physics for those of you is no group
Theory that's the group for those of you
don't ignore that
that thing but basically that gives us
in detail how how gluons are exchanged
in the in the nucleus to hold it
together and why the electron that
orbits around them is is not sucked into
the nucleus because it doesn't
participate in the strong force so here
are the building blocks of the standard
model the quarks the six purple quartz
quarks here the green leptons the
electron and it's sort of heavier
companion or sibling the muon which
decays into the electron and then the
tau which is even heavier and can decay
into the electron of the muon or in fact
it's got some other options that it that
it can do and here are the mediators the
photon mediates the the electromagnetic
force the gluon mediates the strong
force within the nucleus and then the
very heavy W and Z's mediate the weak
force so that's sort of a map you know
it looks very kludgy and qualitative but
it works in detail and it's made
thousands of predictions to very
accurate predictions precise predictions
that appear to be accurate also so but
there is one last problem and this
problem is that this theory of matter of
how matter organizes itself wants
everything to be massless and that's
that's actually a problem and I think it
deserves a very big frowny face so the
problem is and this can't be swept under
the rug we can't just say well you know
the masses are all 0 and we're going to
paste a mass in there because there's
certain things that happen simply
certain symmetries that have to be
obeyed that if you give the particles
mass you know it's very bad so
everything wants to be like the photon
made of fields but but fundamentally
having no rest mass but but the idea the
fix is to propose a ubiquitous field
thats everywhere since massive objects
have mass wherever they are and mass
will be generated through an interaction
between these these massless fields that
are the electron or the cork and and
this ubiquitous field and dynamically
mass will be generated through that
interaction and if you put that into the
theory it works quite well and it really
it you know it doesn't look like a
kludgy sort of a
thought even though it was at some level
so and the nice thing about this theory
is that it has predictive power it
predicts so so that the Higgs works like
this so the Higgs gives mass to objects
whether they're moving or not but the
best way to understand it the best bad
example of the of of how the Higgs works
is that if the electron moves through
the Higgs feels sort of like a particle
through water and therefore we interpret
it as being very light but the top quark
is very heavy and it moves through the
Higgs field as if it was molasses and it
turns out that this molasses can self
interact and give us the molasses ball
which is the Higgs boson and it can only
do that when it's got enough energy to
do that it doesn't spontaneously make
Higgs bosons all over the place it's
gotta conserve energy but but but it
does have this predictive a prediction
that the Higgs boson should exist and
because the masses of the particles are
all wrapped up in the in this theory we
even know roughly where to look for the
Higgs boson so since I know you're a
well-educated have been reading the
newspaper I want to clear up some
misconceptions you might have it was
stated in the news last July that the
Higgs field is responsible for all the
mass in the universe that is certainly
not true so let's talk about our mass
we're made out of neutrons and protons
almost exclusively and and and that mass
the mass of the proton is is really not
from the Higgs interaction so the mass
of the quarks within within the the
proton are gotten through the
interaction with the Higgs but the this
the proton looks something like this it
looks like three quarks that each have
the charge of the strong force so that
and it's a very very powerful charge so
that around it is this intense field a
gluon field but that that that those
gluons are trapped in being exchanged in
between these quarks and trap the quarks
within the proton but this huge amount
of energy via special relativity is
interpreted as mass so here equals MC
squared is really the e of the these
of these fields being interpreted as an
M and that's really what the proton is
only about ten percent comes from the
quarks and most of that is the strange
cork that you know isn't really one of
these three okay so um so that's that's
that so now you might ask the astute
listener might might ask how is it that
these massless fields can give a massive
object well the answer is Einstein said
it could and so therefore it's got to be
true but let me give up a better example
suppose we had a mirrored box and a
laser pointer which we have and we take
two mirrored boxes so on the inside of
these boxes are all mirrors and there's
a there's a little hole you can't really
see that but there's a little hole right
there so we shine our laser pointer into
one of them and lo and behold it will
get heavier now it turns out if you if
you try this with my laser pointer it
turns out it would take between one
hundred five hundred years to pump
enough energy into that box to make it
sort of a microgram heavier so you don't
want to try this at home anyone but it
turns out that people Jack Harris who's
a very clever experimentalist here is
thinking about ways to do something
similar to this and that that is very
exciting so to summarize so far in 1810
the word field hadn't really been used
in physics but but we did sort of map
out field lines and they were a
mathematical convenience but not thought
to be real and by 2013 and of course
mass was certainly thought to be real in
1810 but now we think that everything
that's real is comprised of field so
both matter and light and that mass is
dynamically generated so your masses is
generated from instant to instant as
quarks are swarming around the proton
being emitted and absorbed I'm sorry as
gluons are being emitted and absorbed by
the quarks of in real time and all the
mysteries of this are sort of swept up
into this ubiquitous field thats
everywhere and and this is sort of the
second time we've had one of these
fields that lives everywhere and many
physicists don't really like it but but
where we're stuck with it and if this
theory is correct we r correct as it
somewhat in quotes because it might be
you know a low-energy approximation or
something like that it might be replaced
someday but but if it holds together at
all then we ought to find the Higgs
boson so how do we go about finding the
Higgs well I've implied that the Higgs
is very unstable it lives about 10 to
minus 25 seconds which is pretty darn
quick so you want it you can't just go
out and dig up half of western
Pennsylvania you know put it through
some machine and sort it and look for
Higgs because they're not going to be
there but you can make them if you've
got enough energy so what we do is is
take counter-rotating beams of protons
with very very high kinetic energy and
we collide them head-on and that energy
then is available to make mass so again
we're using e to MC squared taking our
energy of kinetic energy and putting it
into mass and that mass can do many
things but one of the things that can
I'm sorry that energy can do many things
but one of the things that can do is
make a Higgs boson the accelerators the
LHC and here's a sort of a schematic
representation so this is a the Geneva
Airport and this is Geneva and you can't
really see the ring as you as you fly in
because it's about 200 meters
underground but but this is what it
would look like if you had x-ray vision
so there are four big experiments and
Yale is involved in two of them the
Atlas experiment on the upper right and
the Elysee experiment that Helen canes
and John John Harris are involved in so
and and and the the collision energy at
maximum will be seventeen TV or 7,000
I'm sorry 70 EV / beam 14 t EV for the
total and that's an a proton weighs
about a GeV so this is like 14,000 times
the energy of a proton so let's just
walk through some of the details this is
an amazing machine one of the largest
machines in the world it's in a 16-mile
tunnel that it's Underground it's May
it's basically a 16-mile ring of
superconducting magnets that are all at
about two degrees Kelvin takes about
ninety six tons of liquid helium to keep
them that way here's a picture of one of
the last mag the last magnet being
lowered down in April of 2007 through
one of the the access shafts and here's
a picture of the final assembled magnets
in and you can see the gentle curvature
and the person riding in the tunnel just
because he can now the main thing about
the LHC is that it's an amazing machine
and we want to use it again and again
and again so we want to make sure that
when we put beam in it we've got an exit
strategy for how to get the beam out
safely so we it in it that's a big task
because when when particles are going
very close to the speed of light you can
really they can hold a lot of energy and
so if we we have the LHC filled to
capacity at design energy it has the
energy the kinetic the equivalent
kinetic energy of a 747 during takeoff
but that's not the only energy that the
LHC is storing there's a huge amount of
energy in the magnetic field that's used
to bend the the protons trajectory into
this 16 mile circle and that energy is
747 at cruise cruising speed so one has
to be very careful and we've we've tried
very hard to take care with this machine
so our first data from the LHC we have
collision data from September 2008 when
we first started turning on the thing
and collision data we call it collision
data because we're trying to collide
protons with protons but in fact this
was magnet magnet collisions because our
protection didn't really work so we
ended up having an open between two
magnets and that caused this
catastrophic magnetic force that
repelled the magnets and bumped them
there was literally a train wreck where
magnets are bumping into magnets down
the chain and we ruined about 40 magnets
but it turns out we had about 50 spares
and so after readjusting our protection
circuitry in about ten months we are
underway and now I think it is safe to
describe the LHC as
the biggest Swiss watch in the world
it's an amazing machine that functions
amazingly well and we owe a huge debt of
gratitude to those who who did research
and development and prototyping and then
built it and operate it because it's an
amazing scientific instrument so the LHC
can provide data that that will allow us
to see the remnants of the Higgs once it
decays but we have to first understand
what it should decay into turns out that
about eighty percent of the time it
decays into things that that blend in
with the background with the other
things that these high-energy protons
can make when they collide and so we
almost by necessity have to ignore most
of what the Higgs decays into but the
the largest thing that we're currently
actually looking for is looking forward
to decay into the heavy companion to the
electron called the towel and Emma ideal
and Sarah demers are currently looking
for the Higgs decaying into tau pairs
here at Yale and with colleagues at CERN
keith baker is working on trying to see
it in two pairs of the heavy boson the z
and a slightly lighter version of busy
that it's you know it's it's what we
call off shell because it doesn't quite
have enough energy to have its true mass
these are the Z Z star mode is really a
gold plated mode because we'll be able
to reconstruct from these four well
measured particles will be able to tell
the initial mass of the Higgs and the
last mode only happens you know two
times out of a thousand but it's to two
very simple particles two photons and
our energy resolution on photons is very
good and two-photon events are not that
common so we can in a very narrow range
hopefully see an excess of if the Higgs
is there so that's our search strategy
here's a picture of the Atlas detector
that Yale is involved in it you know
when I started in high energy physics
you could put an experiment in a room a
normal sized room
and then then the experiments were sort
of the size of a small house and then
they got to be a size of a big house and
this is more like a city block you know
these are people here and they're not
miniature people it's you know a couple
hundred million electronic channels it
takes many scientists to prepare those
there to prototype them and and and
bring them into existence and then
operate it we have about a thousand
graduate students and lots of other
things on it let's try to briefly
explain how it works we try to learn
different things about the particles in
different regions so within the
innermost region we try to let the
particles pass through without interact
without absorbing them but but sensing
them through very thin wafers of silicon
for example and so we track the particle
there in these regions where we've got
calorimeter as we try to absorb the
total energy of the particles and by
where whether early or late we can learn
about the particles identity and we can
learn about whether it's charged or not
by whether it left a track and the
tracker and if particles made it all the
way through left to track and hits in
the outermost layer we know that that
was very likely a meal on and a neutrino
xscape escapes our detector leaving no
trace but we know that momentum had to
be conserved so by everything going to
one side we know the neutrino had to go
in the other direction so that's
basically how we do our business CMS is
sort of our rival and companion
experiment it's much it's much smaller
but it's more dense so there there you
can see I don't really have time to to
talk about this i know my colleagues at
CMS will probably be miffed at me but
nonetheless we have to move on so CMS is
smaller but it's more dense it weighs
about thirty percent more than the
eiffel tower so it you know this is the
compact detector Atlas it turns out it
weighs about eighty percent of the
Eiffel Tower and had we known that this
slide was going to be shown all over the
world i'm sure we could have brought
twenty percent more mass to the problem
and exceeded the eiffel tower but that
might have been a waste so so the search
itself starts with producing the LHC so
the unfortunate news is
that we only produce a Higgs one every
billion interactions so we're going to
be searching for the the needle among
many haystacks and in it will be hard to
find in the the data collected in 2011
we produced about 70,000 Higgs and
you'll know that we can only play around
with a few hundred of those and really
extract them and unfortunately again we
don't get 10 to the 15 individual
interactions we get about ten at a time
that overlay and that that's problematic
in 2012 we did a little better we got we
got many more hits but of course we had
20 interactions for being crossing as a
cost of the higher intensity intensity
beam and as I said only about two
percent point two percent of all the
Higgs produced end up being
significantly above background in some
mode that we can definitively identify
so here's a here's an example this is a
picture of just the inner part of the
Atlas detector so this is about 20
centimeters across maybe 25 centimeters
across in each of these these planes
here is sort of like the the focal plane
of your of your digital camera and but
it's not really taking an optical image
it's more just looking for a particle to
pass through one of the pixels and give
a current pulse and it has to do that
every 30 nanoseconds or so so it's a
very fast camera and this is what we
hope to c z decaying 22 I'm sorry H
decaying to 2 z's it then give you
something like four muons so here are
the four muons and then here are some
other tracks that it gave but it's
relatively clean but unfortunately what
we see is this where there are 10 other
additional events over top at and easy
curly circles come about because it all
this is is in a solenoid so what excuse
me what we're looking at is proton into
the board proton out of the board the
interaction would be there we started
looking at a cross-section of what
happens as things fly out from from that
interaction region now we can turn the
turn the thing sideways and look sort of
along the beam line and we can see that
these vertices
separate and that really helps us clear
up this problem he can we we can
identify which tracks go with which
vertices and here we've clearly
identified a vertex that as two very
energetic tracks that that that come
from Z boson decay so with these sorts
of techniques we can begin to extract
Higgs from from the background so we use
control samples to a great extent so
this thesis comes from Yale's first PhD
on the Atlas experiment Jennifer shoe in
it shows the reconstruction of the Z
boson when it decays into two electrons
and the line the solid line is our
computer prediction given what we know
about the physics and fineman's rules
versus what we observe in the data and
the points and you can see the agreement
is quite good and that gives us a
confidence that we understand the
tracking chamber that was used for this
and the calorimeter and and our rate of
detecting electrons and so on now with
with much more oops I miss something
something got deleted all right well we
collected millions more bigger samples
than this and with it we've been able to
access just this tail of the
distribution and look at this this
distribution over five orders of
magnitude and see that it also agrees
and if our resolution if our detector
resolution wasn't correct that would not
be correct and and so on so we can
really get to the point where we're
confident that if the Higgs existed we
would see it so then we go and look at
the data and these data are from the
Atlas experiment in the the mode where
we're looking just for for two photons
in the event and of course there'll be
lots of other things and through the
clever use of background samples we can
get the the shape of what the background
should be in the absence of signals and
then we can subtract that off and that's
what we have here we've got the data
points are these data minus this dashed
curve and you can see that that it fits
nicely
to an experimental to the prediction of
what we'd expect our resolution to be if
this object was 125 GeV Higgs we we see
in excess of about 440 events in this
sample we expected about a three
standard deviation of effect and we
observed actually a six standard
deviation effect so we observed about
eighty percent more Higgs than we
expected but we have uncertainties in
our efficiencies and and many things
that that make us less sure that that
eighty percent is is is not a
statistical fluctuation so it'll take
more data for us to really understand
that in fact with new data these numbers
are coming down to closer to what the
standard model is predicting so I in a
second independent set of data we're
looking for the Higgs decaying into four
leptons in the Z Z star a mode that key
professor Keith Baker's looking at so
this this mode is very nice it's almost
self-calibrating this this peak down
here at the bottom is the Z decaying 24
leptons which it does rarely but it does
do quite frequently and much often more
often than the Higgs and we can loosen
up our selection criteria to get more of
them because it's relatively clean and
again we can compare it to what we
expect and the rate is almost exactly as
we expected it to be and the resolution
is is quite similar so that lets us know
that if the Higgs is there we ought to
see it and in fact if you focus here at
125 GeV we've got an excess in plus or
minus five GeV of 125 we see 18 where we
expect only 8.3 and that's about a four
standard deviation effect now our
companion experiment the CMS sees a
lovely two photon data and also 44
lepton data that's consistent with ours
and consistent with a statistical excess
at the same mass and so in terms of
statistics this is not in doubt we found
something new and that's very exciting
so the question is are we finished the
first thing we certainly have discovered
a new object
the question is is is the standard model
complete is this the particle that that
would complete it and that would charge
us to go and measure properties that so
if this if it is the standard model then
Higgs then we know what it will decay
into and we we know certain angular
distributions of what those decay
products should be and we can test those
against what we expect from the standard
model so far the indications are that
this is consistent with the Standard
Model Higgs however we can we can
further and in great detail study what
it decays into at what rates and and how
it does that how its produced and how it
decays and through what are called
quantum fluctuations within the Higgs
and before it decays we can probe much
higher energies than we can directly so
this this is sort of the birth of a new
field of physics and in addition to that
the the standard model is successful as
it is has some rather serious flaws
flaws of omission because it doesn't
talk about dark matter dark energy which
dominate the universe we live in and it
also has some technical problems it it
predicts it has some almost nonsensical
calculations within it that that lead us
to believe that those calculations must
be wrong that some new phenomena must
come in and change how we do those
calculations and they must then those
new phenomena would be new particles or
new forces and we believe they're within
our experimental reach hopefully within
the reach of the LHC as we go up in
energy but of course that's not
guaranteed so let me first summarize the
scientific lessons from from what we
learned we have a relatively complete
picture of mass you know we're good at
it it housed but not so good at why so I
put complete in quotes it's a beautiful
picture of mass it's very elegantly
described by quantum mechanics it in
1810 mass was real and fields were math
and now everything is comprised of
quantized field fields and mass is not
inherent it's dynamically generated in
fact it's calculable with if you input
the proton
mass to qcd calculations you can get the
spectrum of sort of excited states of
excited protons baryons they're called
in detail and it's it's quite exciting
the last piece of the puzzle the higgs
boson is really a huge experimental
turret of force and proceeding it in an
incredible intellectual turret of force
the standard model does contain flaws
and in addition to using this new new
thing the higgs as a scientific
laboratory we're hoping to find
something new beyond the Higgs so now
now we switch from what we know to what
I think so in ode to internationalism so
this big science project was done
internationally and in doing so we we
avoided everybody having one of these in
their own backyard which certainly avoid
duplication of costs it costs about 10
billion dollars so you don't want to do
this in every backyard we spread the
financial burden as broadly as possible
almost every taxpayer on the planet had
skin in the game taxpayers in China
India you know everywhere us South
America almost all taxpayers can
contributed it it helped us develop
patterns of international cooperation in
a relatively non-controversial site
right so we're not trying to do a treaty
to a control global warming or something
even more complicated like maybe trying
to site the Olympics or something we're
just trying to to do a science project
together but yet of course to do it we
all have to have visas from our
countries and so on and we have to
cooperate and and and and so on so it's
a it's a good it's a good way for us to
intertwine the fates of many countries
and I think we did that because we all
wanted this to succeed and what's really
nice is that everybody on the results
right this isn't an American result it's
not a Western result or you know some
hundred countries represented in this
discovery so everybody owns it as it
should be so an ode to taxes taxes are
what we pay for civilized society
over Wendell Holmes I think curiosity
driven risk research is an excellent use
of our our common resources which is to
say taxes it allows us to spread out
these things that are that are
potentially not very practical so
high-energy physics has given in CERN
have given the world many great things
from the World Wide Web to you know
whatever but but if one wanted spin-offs
you wouldn't start by saying let's find
the Higgs boson I'm sure we'll get a lot
of spin-offs that way you'd spend your
money differently so this is really
motivated by curiosity by the human
condition which is curious about our
surroundings and the beautiful world we
live in which seems appropriate to study
the alternatives to doing this curiosity
based research with taxes is to not do
the science at all which is certainly a
possibility or to try to find corporate
sponsors you know if that's even
possible but of course there you're
mixing a for-profit and not-for-profit
entities and and that could get very
complicated it might be how this hat
takes place in the future but I think
that's a less I think that could be very
messy so then we can ask it has this
been worth it so being a taxpayer it
probably cost you a couple dollars over
the last two two decades of your tax
money to find the Higgs and I hope you
found it worthwhile so it's it's cheap
compared to the cost of a movie ticket
think about it that way but and it was
spread over two decades so that's good
now Robert Fineman as he was trying to
justify Fermilab which was built in the
70s said that Fermilab or high energy
physics has nothing directly to do with
defending our country except to make it
worth defending he was he was trying to
argue that we should build this
Accelerator lab instead of another
defense lab and I I think that's true
this money is worth it because it
because it helps us do what humans like
to do we are innately curious and if
we're busy being curious we're not
killing each other there's a lot of good
things that come out of us being curious
so you could ask about opportunity cost
so given other global needs can the
planet afford this
quote unquote frivolous activity and I
this question was raised to me because
after the op-ed piece that Tom mentioned
I got some blowback basically many
people thought this op-ed was very
self-serving which of course it was but
others said you know what would prefer
what I got 11 email in particular that
said I wonder what Professor Tipton
would say to the 25,000 parents who lost
children due to preventable diseases
today and that of course is a very
serious question that we have to address
and so after some thought and a glass of
wine I answered the gentleman and we had
a give and take that was actually quite
quite used useful so that one one way of
addressing this is that it's uh it's
it's not obvious that poverty and
preventable disease are financially
limited anyway it's probably war in
corruption that they keep that from
happening and you know many will argue
with them but Jeffrey Sachs says that of
order point seven percent of the GDP of
the developed world could and using it
wisely could could end poverty so people
can argue with that but that's a
ballpark figure now that should be
compared to four point seven percent of
the the GDP we spend on defense and
point 0 1 percent that we spend on
particle physics research so if sex is
right you know you could cancel all of
high-energy physics and you wouldn't do
much to help us out of the mess we're in
ok so my second to last slide I just
want to spend a minute doing a funny
sort of mental exercise so in my field
we do it what are called pseudo
experiments we we simulate samples of
data with computer-generated models and
we do this millions of times to try to
you know understand the the breadth of
possibilities and the statistical nature
of what we're about to see so these are
called pseudo experiments and I want to
imagine running human history a million
times as we run our experiments a
million times on the computer so this is
something we can actually do but it's so
it's a Gedanken experiment it's
something that that Einstein would would
would have us think about doing an
experiment you can't really do but you'd
like to do
so we've been around for about 200,000
years so let's try to replay this
200,000 years many many times say a
million times how often in in those
million times would we get to develop
symbolic culture in a written language
so symbolic culture has probably been
around for a hundred thousand years
through may be ornamental jewelry and
and things like that that probably
expressed something symbolically to
written language that it's probably more
like twenty thousand years i think i
hope i have that right so it's
relatively late in in our 200,000 years
history it might be that we never would
have gotten to it in 200,000 years would
we reach the bronze age would we be able
to manipulate money would we get to
indoor plumbing this is on many people's
minds i think you know this is this is a
huge human advancement would we get to
the scientific method i note that we've
only had the scientific method for 500
of those 200,000 years so you can well
imagine that that you humans could have
been around for 200,000 years and not
got to the scientific method which of
course would mean we wouldn't get to
special relativity and nuclear power
which is bad but of course we wouldn't
have been able to blow ourselves up
which is good so it's amazing that we've
gotten this far and we haven't blown
ourselves up and then we went further
developed quantum mechanics quantum
field theory predicted the Higgs and
then we're able to have the affluence in
permission of society to to go out and
spend the billions to bring it about now
koat this is very physics centric you
know the mechanical engineer would say
that you know how often would we get to
the development of the wheel and how
often would that lead to the Segway and
so on but but in physics this is this is
how we look at the world and you know uh
you know i'm i'm really not sort of a
mr. rogers type are much more like the
two grumpy guys in the back of the room
and the muppets you know but but I I do
have to say that that you know up with
people right we got it right this time
it's very self-serving for me to say
that what I was involved in is sort of
the pinnacle of human society and
believe me I know that there's a lot of
sausage made in high energy physics
there's a lot of politics and backbiting
and you know it's not all wonderful and
you know
we certainly express all of the emotions
and actions and abilities of human
behavior but we at least helped us to a
common goal of the scientific discovery
so to summarize I don't know why so
beyond the sign so here's the summarize
my opinions the Higgs discovery was
quite global so I don't know why I
thought that a scoreboard was an
appropriate way to finish this talk but
this is a scoreboard that you might
appreciate so the Higgs discovery was
quite global and that's score one for
international cooperation in 04 sort of
a material nationalistic rancor and so
on it was supported by practically every
taxpayer on on the planet so score one
for the glories and virtues of Taxation
and 0 for Hyper end of individualism it
was brought about without corporate
sponsorship and so it's the Higgs boson
it's not the microsoft boson which you
know it could have gone that way so I
think that's a good thing human
curiosity trumped all it we were able to
get beyond ourselves and do something
that at its root is is based in
curiosity and not you know the profit
motive or other human activities that
are perfectly fine so strike one for
human curiosity and 0 for motives lower
on maslow's hierarchy so what about
opportunity cost well as 114 big science
and 0 for everything else for example
curing eliminating pure evil diseases
but I think that's a false dichotomy I
don't think that we have to make that
choice and we have enough resources to
do to do it all or to do at least those
do thank you very much for your
attention
okay i know probably delighted to answer
your questions so please yes Machado in
one of your slides you said the
non-controversial isn't that a bit
dangerous if there is no more
controversy in science what what today
in in what context was so so Michelle is
asking me I'm in one in in one on one
slide I said something was
non-controversial so what what in what I
don't remember writing that down I deny
it I think you said this in relation to
the unity of the team was teamwork
because noncontroversial oh oh no what I
meant was that what we were doing was
not controversial like trying to put a
treaty on global warming we were all
deciding you know we had all signed up
to try to find to do discovery physics
at the LHC so in that sense it was not
controversial we weren't at odds over
our basic premise for why we were in the
room at most days so in that sense it
was not controversial it was absolutely
i mean many of us i have to go on record
now as saying that i never thought this
thing was there the Higgs just felt too
weird you know we're going back to the
ether right this ubiquitous field is
everywhere I don't like this idea at all
but it's there and it actually is quite
elegant even though I don't like it and
so in its and it's probably true so yes
I think there were many dissenters in
the room but all of us wanted to know
the answer you know I think they're
certainly we're biases and and hopefully
we put those aside yes
so it it that the Higgs field gives all
elementary particles the quarks and the
leptons the W and the mediators the w's
in disease but but not the photon it
leaves the photon alone it gives those
absolutely fundamental entities their
mass so so just like in Argo i can give
you our best bad analogy you know the
best bad analogy is that is that we move
the as particles move through this
ubiquitous ether it's like a drag force
and and that the drag is proportional to
how strongly the the particle couples to
the Higgs field and so heavy objects
couple strongly and light objects don't
couple strongly and move through it
quite well now the flaw in that argument
and flaw in that analogy is that the
Higgs gives mass to objects whether
they're moving or not this is not about
resisting acceleration or resisting
motion so it is a flawed argument but
it's the best flawed argument we have I
can pick yes faster objects are moving
the more mass they have so the question
is is is this related to Einstein's
ideas about time dilation is is moving
through the Higgs field like that and
the answer is no for for the exact
reason I just said that objects have
masked whether they're moving through
the feet Higgs field or not massless
objects like photons don't even know the
Higgs field is there it's like it's like
a neutral object not knowing that
there's an electric field there right
that's
sweta why there wouldn't be a lot more
massive ought to us but of course not to
themselves like yeah so there is some
zur observer now who thinks you're
moving very close to the speed of light
but you obviously don't think you're
heavier than you normally are yes so the
question is I mentioned space-time in
mass is the big three and you said how
about energy and that the truth is the
best definition of mass is that it's
it's a very common form of energy and
it's the most common form of really
really dense energy right so so it
appears to be anomalous but it's
actually and it perhaps is because it's
also the charge of gravity so it
probably is special but yes it is just a
form of energy and general relativity is
a theory of gravity but it's also a
theory of how energy couples to a matter
into it to its itself oh so so the
question is about dark energy and how
that works and I can answer that very
easily we don't know how dark energy
works yeah that would be an excellent
PhD thesis for all of you following
along at home write that down that's a
great bit topic so there's a lot about
dark energy that we have just begun to
touch yes Peter big project might
involve you know five or ten students we
have a hard time often finding out I
know what they do and still have like a
productive
happy outcome and even when there's two
students doing the same thing with
sometimes worry you now having said et
cetera now a class alone had a thousand
a thousand PhD students yeah so the
question is about the sociology of large
experiments how is it that we can have a
thousand graduate students and know what
each is doing and and be able to advance
their careers by understanding what they
do individually and and you said that in
astronomy we really don't like to have a
student do two students do the same
topic and that's true in high energy
also there are hundreds and hundreds of
interesting things to do with in atlas
rarely do we have students doing exactly
the same thing so i showed you sort of
what are called the cut and count
there's other people are doing this with
neural nets there there are people
looking in various decay modes or people
who wrote a thesis on the first part of
the data and now postdocs so you can
divide it up many ways and have
individual ownership of work and ideas
and and so on what we have to do is rely
on on letters of recommendation because
you can't just point to a publication
list because as Tom pointed out to me I
have 850 publications and that's an
embarrassing number you know I yes the
papers / author I'm pretty low so when
ad list publishes a paper we have of
order is it about two thousand names
signing it so you know so I and many of
those papers i only own like 12
thousandth of the paper so it all works
out yes
remember I was actually so that the
question is how do we how do we know to
what what sets our schedule basically
Wow why is it we made an announcement at
a certain time so there are certain big
so it high-energy physics is highly
ritualized we have these conventions and
conferences every year and you go there
and pay homage and stuff so our schedule
revolves around these conferences so
then the accelerator sets is scheduled
around these conferences and so then the
accelerator when when they give us the
data is set so that we have a big slug
of data right before these conferences
and can analyze it and and and so it's
sort of self-fulfilling prophecy that we
get big results before big conferences
because that's how we designed it and
why these you know why these conferences
happen to be the lucky ones you know
it's kind of crazy but that's that's
basically what's going on and and we try
to give data and you know lots of big
conferences come and go without major
discoveries it's when you get that
biggest log of data before an important
conference and everybody's ready
Catherine if you have a Newtonian world
view of a sort of you that measurements
can be observed and you know reliable
laws by which the world can be
understood and then you have an Einstein
Ian worldview of perspective what would
the Higgs boson Ian worldview be the
philosophical implications and that's
very interesting that's very and so the
question was Newton gave us a certain
way of looking at the world sort of
about the the classical the world is a
is a well-made clock and then Newton and
Einstein sort of broad in relativity and
and that you know it depends on your
perspective so what what philosophy
would be informed by the Higgs that is
really an excellent question let me know
when you get an answer I
I i I'm sure there I'm sure it's just a
short sightedness on my part not being
able to come up with something but you
know and maybe in 50 years it will be
obvious and people laugh at me for not
knowing the answer but I I don't you
know it's sort of the the quantum view I
guess but do any of the other physicists
in the room have an answer yeah the
quantum world that things are understood
statistically but it in the high
statistic limits you get back what
Einstein and and and Newton would have
predicted and so it's a radical
departure you know we can't tell where
each electron is going in fact the
electron doesn't even have a position
until you measure it so that's sort of
crazy making in a different way that
Einstein was crazy making but in the end
of the day you make measurements and
compare it to theory and it's all good
great question let's have two more oh
yes okay so the question is why why
don't we solve this issue of a big
authors the way the French mathematician
big groups of authors of a French
mathematicians did and i would say that
getting all those friends mathematicians
to make a decision and is anomalous i
mean for us to be able to get it in a
room and make a decision i've actually
been in the room where we tried to do
things differently let's just have first
author be the graduate student but then
which great you know if there are two
graduate students they contributed you
know and and it's so it just gets messy
and and again it's sort of our this is
our best worst idea right it's our best
bad idea and and and the astronomers do
it differently and perhaps better they
they do get together to do these big
projects but then when they publish they
publish in small groups in in in high
energy we do our work in small groups
but then everybody is on it that's why i
have 850 publications
in truth I'm only doing two or three
serious publications a year with with my
group and and those really count and
those are the ones i highlight and and
so on but yeah we're stuck with the
system unfortunately yes blue turtleneck
oh I'm sorry no no we got to go with the
yes so the question was was I surprised
or did did I ever was i surprised about
the level of attention and did I feel
like it was perhaps bad that's that's
also very good question I was surprised
I mean I I was involved in a fairly big
discovery in in 1994 at Fermilab and
that was a big deal and I was really at
the center of it and you know it was it
was huge there were lots of articles and
I thought it was great this is so much
bigger and I had no idea it would be so
much bigger and so I was surprised and
do I think it's bad I mean you paid for
it you know don't read the newspapers if
you don't want you know don't go to the
movie right you you you paid to go to
this movie you paid to make this movie
but you don't have to go to it so you
can ignore it i thought it was good i
thought you know there were aspects that
were bad like yeah i'm always harking
back to the god particle which you know
is flamboyant and that was that was
invented to sell books and it did but it
hasn't served us well and so that that's
probably the only aspect of this that
has been negative now I think it's good
for science I think it's good we're
sharing one mic here so let me on behalf
of the entire group thank Paul for this
lovely talk that really got us up to
speed on